Dr.
Peterson,
I heard you recently say that if a woman
doesn't want a baby by age 30,
that something is unhealthy.
I take no offense to that assertion.
Rather I am taking it very seriously.
I'm 34 years old in a longterm
relationship but don't feel desire to
have children.
I always thought that I would one day
but I'm getting older and that I'm
getting older and that day still hasn't
come.
I'm terrified of raising,
realizing too late that I should have
had a family.
But I'm also terrified of having them
and regretting it because I never truly
want it to be a mother.
I don't think I have any ideology of
play.
I'm not a feminist or anything like
that.
When you say something might be wrong or
unhealthy,
where might I look?
Any advice on how to make this change?
What won't make this choice?
Ps,
my boyfriend and I both had he depaul
mothers perhaps that is relevant.
Well it might be relevant given that you
saw fit to um,
include it as a potential detail.
And one of the rules that I would
operate by as a psychotherapist is that
if a client is inclined to add a detail
to the,
to the formulation of a problem,
that the details are likely to be
relevant.
Um,
but I can't tell,
right?
Because of course I can't use it a rule
of thumb.
And so you might object,
well,
I shouldn't have used to rule of thumb
to say something like if a woman doesn't
want a baby by the age of 30,
that something is unhealthy.
Well,
they're going to be exceptions to every
general rule.
But my attitude to this essentially is
that we have all come from an unbroken
string of 3.5
million years of successful mothers.
And so the probability that that's going
to be part and parcel of,
um,
healthy woman's desire and not only a
woman,
no.
Obviously men desire to have a family
too and often very intensely.
It's just that men have a much longer
time span over which to consider such
things.
Uh,
so perhaps the chips are down so rapidly
and to the same degree for men.
Um,
I wouldn't be so bold as to say that
there's anything wrong with you,
the questioner specifically.
Um,
maybe you have the sort of temperament
that isn't particularly inclined towards
maternal behavior.
Uh,
that might be someone who's low in
agreeableness and well,
that would be the primary issue.
Um,
and so I wouldn't take my word for it,
that if you don't want to have a child
in your 30,
that there is necessarily something
specifically wrong with you.
But I would say as a rule of thumb,
it's,
it's part of the normal panoply of human
desires and values.
And so if,
if,
if there's violent objection to having a
family,
something like that,
then generally that seems to me to be
indicative of something that might be at
least worth looking into.